vous exercez un métier de l'ombre
conseillère technique dans un cabinet
ministériel sous le gouvernement de
lionel jospin vous travaillez pour la
secrétaire d'état aux droits des femmes
et à la formation professionnelle nicole
péry nous sommes en 1998 vous avez 39
ans
[Musique]
je crois qu'on est tous conscients ici
que les liens entre emploi et formation
entre travail et formation sont telles
que le sujet ne peut pas être
complètement autonome même si et je
crois que c'est ça qui est important
aussi dans le travail de nicole il faut
qu'on arrive à redéfinir quand même les
finalités propre de la formation vous
souvenez de ce moment de cette première
samira je me souviens de pas vraiment en
fait de ce moment je me souviens bien
sûr j'étais au cabinet de nicole péry et
de martine aubry puisque c'était le même
ministère et nicole péry et nommé
à la formation professionnelle
on n'est pas très nombreux autour d'elle
à ce moment là et je me souviens qu'on
est en train d'essayer de définir
est ce qu'il faut faire une réforme une
grande réforme accompagner on était
aussi dans dans la loi sur les 35 heures
est un peu plus tard une école perry va
devenir aussi secrétaire d'état aux
droits des femmes mais voilà je me
souviens tout de moi c'était pas quand
même
[Musique]